now miles if you had told me at any
point before the evening hours of
tuesday march 16 the broncos would be
trading for a quarterback the day before
the draft
i would have placed money on the
possibility that that quarterback is
desean watson
watson's name continues to hover over
this draft for one very important reason
things have gotten very quiet
in
a litigation
22 individuals all suing to sean watson
it was news news news news news public
pressure battle of the lawyers instagram
press conferences press releases back
and forth they were in court on friday
for a status conference allegations of
destruction of evidence
something happened after
they walked out of that courtroom on
friday can't prove it don't know it
this is just circumstantial evidence as
far as i'm concerned based on 18 years
of practicing law and understanding how
leverage works and the leverage
for a maximum settlement of these cases
against desean watson dictates getting
it done now getting it done before the
draft before the end of the draft before
rosters are fully baked in
for the 2021
off-season program training camp
pre-season
and
i think don't know
but i think
that the lawyers are trying to resolve
these cases and just be ready be ready
for the double lightning strike boom
22 cases resolved
power
deshawn watson traded somewhere between
now and sunday miles you can't rule it
out and uh unless and until the lawyers
start squabbling publicly again which
would mean it all fell apart or they're
making one last run at pressuring the
other side to agree to their terms it
feels like something may happen it's the
proverbial calm before the storm and
i won't be surprised if it happens
well so mike i think the biggest thing
there is that what you're talking about
with the lawyers right if these guys are
really saying
that there's something that can be
resolved here then that's probably
what's going to happen because they're
not saying anything publicly anymore and
i feel like every time that you and i
would be doing a show there would be
something to say about desean watson
pretty much every single day and since
it's been you know this whole week you
know it just really has not been
anything that's been coming out from
either camp and from that standpoint it
just seems like you're definitely right
these things are quiet now because
they're starting to resolve every single
issue so i think it certainly would be
interesting if these things do get
resolved these cases actually really
call them things get resolved you know
before or during the draft so that it
allows the texans to have some sort of
time to get desean watson off of their
roster and other team to say all right
this is what we are willing to trade for
deshaun watson because at that point you
still have
more value than you might otherwise when
it comes to deshaun watson i mean i
don't know what his value is at this
point now especially because he still
could be facing a suspension
from the league after everything that
has happened here so
i'm not sure what the value would be i'm
not sure you know it how teams would
really gauge their interest in what in
in trading for desean watson but yeah it
if this starts to get resolved if the
cases do start to get resolved then it
would not surprise me either to then see
deshaun watson moved because at the end
of the day
he's still the kind of quarterback that
teams are going to want on their team
because he is clearly a very very
productive player and he's played at an
elite level before and there's no reason
to think that he can't get back there
again
i'll see your could be suspended and
raise you will will be suspended i can't
imagine the nfl
walking through this
minefield without resolving the
situation
by
an unpaid suspension of desean watson
the ben roethlisberger president from 11
years ago would apply here and at one
point
i actually found excerpts of the letter
that the commissioner sent
roethlisberger and some of the same
concepts some of the same reasoning
would apply to watson even if there's an
agreement as part of the settlement that
he admits to no wrongdoing and let's say
allegations of forced activities are
retracted by the handful of persons who
have claimed that even with all that the
pattern of behavior
the nfl i think we'll say requires
intervention and if ben roethlisberger
got suspended six games reduced to four
as a result of two
incidents one a civil lawsuit one a
potential prosecution potential lawsuit
that i think was privately and
confidentially settled if that happens
for two for him and you have 22 for
deshaun watson i don't think he comes
out of it unscathed but but
if you trade for him
you go into it knowing okay we may be
looking at four games six games eight
games maximum we're still trading for
the guy we're still making the move
because this solves our issue and
and the other side of it miles to the
extent that there's compensation in 2022
draft picks that would be part of this
you could very easily pick at least for
one of the selections
a scale based upon what his suspension
is if he suspended more than six games
it's an extra fourth round pick if he
suspended four games it's an extra third
round pick if it's fewer than four games
it's an extra second round pick
something like that you can do whatever
you want to do from a creativity
standpoint and i i think that he will
get suspended
but that won't stop a team from making
the trade if the lawsuits are gone
and the book is closed on any potential
criminal investigation i think that's
going to be enough to get someone to
pull the trigger on a trade
yeah because when you're thinking about
a quarterback you're not just doing that
for 2021 or 2022 you're doing it
ostensibly to set yourself up at qb
through 2030 because that is the kind of
player that you think desean watson can
be i think it's the kind of player that
pretty much all of us seem to think that
desean watson could be
based on the things that he's done in
the league so far so this is not just
something that teams would do for now
it's for the future as well so i i think
that's why it sets up for a team to say
yes we're willing to take that hit that
whatever it might be
from in terms of pr standpoint you know
from a suspension standpoint in 2021
because for the rest of the decade and
maybe even into the 2030s we are set up
at quarterback and we are set up to go
after winning a championship
john mcclaney houston chronicle recently
reported that eight teams were
interested before
the legal issues arose dolphins jets
patriots broncos washington chicago
carolina san francisco now of those only
miami has not yet addressed its
quarterback needs every other team has
made a move the patriots re-signing cam
newton the jets
they're going to take zach wilson at
number two broncos now have teddy
bridgewater i don't think that would
stop them from trading for deshawn
watson washington has ryan fitzpatrick i
don't know that that would stop them
from trading for deshaun watson bears
with andy dalton same panthers sam
darnold same i think the only ones that
fall out of the 49ers who moved up to
number three
and the jets who hold the second overall
pick those are the ones who fall out
miami is the i think leader and the
other team
that wasn't reported by john mcclane
miles that i think we need to keep an
eye on
is the philadelphia eagles i've been
told for weeks that if and when watson
is in play they will be inclined to try
to buy low get a franchise quarterback
and not be troubled by
how the off-field issues could impact
fan reaction whatever
look they're the team that brought mike
vick back to the nfl they're not going
to
hesitate to give deshaun watson his next
chance especially because they're just
desperate to get a franchise quarterback
for sure look i think we've already seen
that uh what they think of jalen hurts
is at least for now he's got to be in
competition at qb in order to maybe
secure a role and who knows if he's
going to be in competition with joe
flacco or if they're going to pick up
somebody else
in this upcoming draft tomorrow night or
over the course of the next few days so
i think that certainly the eagles could
be in play it seems to make sense look
any team that really does not have a
franchise quarterback already could
still be in play right i mean whether
we're talking about the the patriots
there whether we're talking about miami
who ostensibly has one with to a tag of
iloa those those quarterbacks are all
probably not as good right now as desean
watson is so i think from that
standpoint it would make sense if teams
are going to inquire about sean watson
and you say look i have this price for
him and this is what i am willing to
give up in order to get someone like
desean watson based on everything in all
of the circumstances that have gone on
over the last couple of months so
there's a lot to this but i'd certainly
think that you know when you're thinking
about the eagles specifically that would
be very very interesting if you go from
somebody like carson wentz to then
deshawn watson as your franchise
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports